[Music]
my last clinical which is like an
internship was uh with this really great
psychiatrist finnish clinical
a couple days later he sends me this
long-winded message about how he has
feelings for me
which i do not have for him i'm so sorry
that you got put in this position i'm
kind of angry about it
[Music]
what up what up what up this is john
with the dr john delony show
so glad that you're with us
hope you're doing well if your family's
doing well the show we talk about mental
health relationships is the best mental
health show ever um as declared by me
and my 12 year old and a six-year-old
does not agree but my 12-year-old does
hey the other day
i was showing my son something on the
internets
and
he saw me my own show in the feed
so we looked at the comments together i
thought that'd be a good exercise for
him
it wasn't but
somebody said my pre
call banter is cringy
you're right it's so crazy
everyone in the booth is like yeah
that's for sure cringy so i'm sorry
i think i'm cringy that's what my wife
says all right let's go to renee in
waynesboro
renee what's up renee
hi how are you doctor john how are we
doing i'm good how are you i'm just
we're figuring it out having fun you
doing well
yes sorry i got a little bit of a throat
thing going on hey no problem so what's
up how can i help
so i'm i'm doing great i graduated last
week and i'm looking for a job would you
graduate
i'm a i'll be a psychiatric nurse
practitioner once i take my board
congratulations you're a real
professional that's fantastic
thank you that's so great good for you
thank you and my last clinical which is
like an internship was uh with this
really great psychiatrist which is where
my question comes in um everything was
going great finished clinical
a couple days later he sent me this
long-winded message about how he has
feelings for me
which i do not have for him
um so my question is like
if i
feel pretty okay with it can i go ahead
and still take a job i have an interview
at the end of the month at the same
clinic it's not his clinic but he works
there
talk about cringy so um
yeah
so
i've got so many feelings before we go
forward i just have to say
i'm so sorry that you got put in this
position
yeah i was kind of i'm i'm kind of angry
about it hey listen
be super angry about it be
furious about it because i'm pissed
on behalf of that's a if you haven't had
a clinical rotation supervisor like you
have i had one
those relationships are
i wish was a better word they're very
intimate right because people are
walking you through like you're helping
people you lose people you get scared
you have hard conversations what do you
feel like those are deep relationships
and so when somebody's a clinical
supervisor
um they have to
be so above board
understanding the power hierarchy there
and understanding this the sword they
wield over their their
i'm just sick man i'm so sorry that's
wrong at every every level across
everything so how did how did this come
about just out of the blue sends you
this long message
well
so everything you just said right and
then we did get close we i thought we're
good friends he was a great mentor
i felt really good about everything he's
so intelligent he to the point he's sort
of to me kind of teeters that line
between
he's essential he's very eccentric um
and i think i don't want to presume to
tell someone how they feel but i think
he just got a little confused because i
consider myself very non-judgmental so
when he says like shares weird things
about his experiences or the way he
thinks i'm like oh okay well tell me
more you know that's why i'm in this
profession i think it's interesting i
don't care if you're a little bit odd
you know
um and so maybe that friendliness or
that that openness came across
in a way that he misread
i i i'm so sorry and i know this is your
experience i got to stop you is that
okay yeah
not my fault i want you to own zero of
this
right yeah if you were flirty and you
were like
man
you and me when this rotation is over
we are going to burn the city to the
ground like if that had been you
it's his
oh you say no way no way
no
no well and so like i like i say i was i
was nice to him and that's about the
only thing i can think that maybe he
misconstrued
and i should mention he's also
20 some maybe 24 5 years older than me
and i'm married to a female
so
which we talked about so there is no uh
dumb and dumber so you're telling me
there's a chance right that's there's
not even
right so listen uh to go back
if you had been trying as his um
clinical subordinate as one of his
students if you will
to hook up with him
he has an ethical obligation
to no longer be
your supervisor and to bring that to
some sort of border at board of ethics
and so often
there's hard conversations about like
when people get relationship stuff and
mixed signals and i've been in enough
um
sexual assault investigations over my
career that some of those are very clear
some of those are very very messy that's
just the truth
this is not and here's because of the
power hierarchy
he is the clinical supervisor and so if
somebody was to come on to him in a
predator if you were bananas as a
predator
it's his job to create the space
backwards and to call in your ethics and
in your uh character and fitness not
to be like oh really maybe you know what
i mean it's just the whole thing's gross
and i hate this for you because here's
why
there really is not a non-messy way
forward for you
yeah and i hate that how old are you
35 okay so you've i mean you're not 23
and so you know this but i'm just gonna
spell it out is that okay
yeah
you're either
gonna pretend this never happened and
it's gonna eat your soul
the rage the anger will get loud right
or um
you're going to apply for this job and
you're going to get it and you're going
to see this dude and you're going to try
to be like ah sounds cool
and
i may be overstating this but i don't
think i am you would be the one to
finally to speak to this but
that same fight or flight reflex will
that's supposed to trigger when there's
a bear at the door will understand that
every time you pull into that parking
lot there's that bear there
that is potentially going to use his
power and influence and
superiority as a supervising physician
to put me in a position that i want to
be in right um or
um you decide to burn his career to the
ground which it should be
and
um that may be too strong of a statement
i don't i'm just so grossed out by this
and so i'm
making sweeping statements here you're
gonna burn his
his situation down his career down
and then you're gonna be that person in
the office you know what i'm saying
there's just not a messy way forward and
i hate that for you
i do too because well there's a few
other things so
but wait there's more
i'm trying to rationalize because
there's just not many jobs where i'm at
and i do want to work
so here's my rationalization tell me if
it's crazy so
he worked part-time there and part-time
a different place
and the part-time at this clinic is two
different locations so the one location
that i would be at is only there once a
week
now
if i go full time i can do four days a
week so maybe i could just avoid them um
this is
like
i'm sure i would still no no you're a
night you're a psychiatric nurse
practitioner
i know you're on the other end of this
of
do you have just listen to the words
you're saying
i know
you will be on the other end of this
interview with a countless number of
patients in the clients in the future
and you'll hear yourself
maybe if i just don't wear this
particular thing on this day
then he won't be tempted to or maybe if
i you hear that's happening
yeah
yeah
and it happens to the best of us i've
been there too
where you start back well maybe if i
just dude
i'm so sick for you so here's my here's
my
six foot two
white
male 200 pound guy okay
i walk in and
full of bluster and texas ego and i sit
down with the hr director and say i'm a
finalist for this position
and i'm going to print out all those
texts and say and this just happened and
i really want this job and i deserve
this job and my record that you all have
on file suggests that i'm qualified for
this job
but i can't be here because this guy is
a predator because here's what my
experience working as an administrator
and and um
on like with my experience with as a
minister with law students in a similar
character and fitness thing is if this
if this were to be made known my guess
is you're not the first
i know that's sad that's strange too
this is probably a pattern of behavior
if this person's what 5th 60 right 58.
and they've spent their career mentoring
young p students i wouldn't surprise me
if this is is not
maybe you are the angel snowflake
unicorn that came from heaven just to be
in his rotation but um my guess is this
is a pattern of behavior
but i can't tell you that's the right
path
right
because they can also say um you're not
hired
and then you're gonna have a lawsuit and
you'll probably actually win it but the
question would be for what right
right
yeah
and so let me ask you this
[Applause]
this guy needs to have his license taken
away at least or at least not be allowed
to work with students anymore
okay my thought is usually once
unethical in one area they're unethical
across the board but i feel pretty
strongly about this and for people
listening and you're like dude chill out
he just asked a girl out that he was
working
you got to just trust me and i can hear
it in your voice renee that the
relationship between a supervisor and
their
practicum students is so intimate and
it's so heavy and it's so power laden
right because any moment he could have
written do not does not she's not
meeting standard or
uh does not have good bedside manner and
it's hard to quantify those things and
you're just out on your ear right so
the fact that somebody's preying on you
with
and you're rather vulnerable in that
relationship it just grosses me out man
he's got to be better than that so
where do you want to be when this is
over
my clinical he did wait till i finish
i'll give him that oh how sweet
he does know that i was i had an
interview there later this month
oh i do have interviews there he knew
that so yeah it's still kind of yeah
um
so what you're i mean clearly you're
brilliant where do you want to where do
you want to be what do you want to do
well that's kind of why i want to go
there because they're offering me
um
the opportunity to work from
kids adults elderly developmental delay
intellectually like across the board is
where i would have experienced that i
could see you know what i want to do
let me ask you a hard question
yeah who do you want to be when this is
over
oh well
it's i mean professionally i just i
really want to be a really great
practitioner like i want i really want
to dig into my career
and
i just want to i don't really want to
put him under professionally
unless it were to continue to be a
problem or something you know he put
himself under as far as i'm concerned
but i i also get your sentiment um
that's why
that's why in these kind of situations i
to be careful because
um
i have a particular disdain for some of
this that not everybody shares and i'm
not in the middle of that situation
the other side of it is um
let me take a more graceful approach
but you know him better than better than
i do
say you walk in and say hey i got your
message dude
we can't have this
right is that a
i
possibility i i it was a message a text message and
i said i i respect you as a professional
colleague and
and it'll never be anything else and i
haven't heard anything else um
so i mean i did put i was very direct
and and that's been the end of it so far
so
um
has this happened to you before
unwanted advances
yes i'm a woman in america thank you you
idiot
um
uh
i mean
not that as much as
um
the power differential
no well no i take that back yes one i
had a nursing supervisor who i was
working with
and um
that was also very inappropriate he was
also much older and i basically did the
same thing i just shut it down okay
yeah
so when i ask you who do you want to be
at the end of this here's what i'm
getting at
some people can be comfortable
uh
i didn't want to say that
i guess i just seem to say i'm sorry
this happened to you now you're in a
funky position
um i'm very uncomfortable with unwanted
male attention if that's what you mean
and it makes me very uncomfortable yes
and you layer on top of that a
significant power right because this is
a supervising
physician so six months from now you're
working there and you write a report
and he tries again and you say no and he
writes
this person is not doing what they're
supposed to be doing that becomes part
of your file right
and so that's what i don't i don't like
the the end of where this can go
because even if you take this job as an
np
you're still quote-unquote under his
supervisor supervisory authority correct
yeah and i think
there is one other doctor there but he's
not there very often at all but i don't
know if he could be my collaborator or
not and for the listener let's make this
even more complicated psychiatrists are
hard to come by
and so it's not like the hospital is
going to be like shoot get that guy out
here we got a new guy here on monday
they would say hey we have to do the
right thing and get rid of this person
oh and by the way there's nobody else to
fill that
spot two-year waiting list to see it
like he's very high regarded they're not
i don't
they're not gonna
oh i shouldn't say that i haven't talked
to anybody about it but so let me ask
you this what are you gonna do
oh no
that's why i called you doctor
oh man
um i'm um
leaning towards just if you're not gonna
like this i'm leaning towards just doing
it
but um i don't i don't know that that's
the best decision and just kind of
between a rock and hard so so
let me give you some piece here
what i'm gonna like is the decision that
you choose you're grown up and you're
brilliant okay
um
i will ask you to do a couple of things
yeah number one
keep a printed record of every single
thing
every text message every response every
email all those things
okay
um if for some reason you go in and
don't get this job
i think you have every reason to believe
it's because you shunned his advances
at that point
if i'm you if you're my sister you're my
daughter i'm telling you
um
you've got to go make your concerns
heard
if um
yeah i can't tell you to go burn it down
just because there's so many variables
to that situation um i just want you to
do this follow your gut because you're
smart
um
make sure you've got somebody that
you're talking to as you walk into this
okay
yeah and please please please don't bury
who you are and your value and your
worth for a job
okay
all right
you promised me that
yeah i do okay
you're right
man i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i wish
there was a it's one of those calls i
wish there was like some great like and
then and then yeah
it's going to be a mess
because like again again i can talk
about something i keep thinking you're
going to bring these forward and he's
going to have five things that he's like
no she said this and then she did this
and like i keep going back to dumb and
dumber and then she touched my leg and
then there's like a thing and then a
thing
and then it's gonna end in some hr
stalemate and there's gonna be a letter
in his file that's gonna be like we
and then you've got an awkward work
situation and uh this just goes on and
on and on so i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i'm sorry
yuck
yuck
ladies and gentlemen if you are in a
position of power over somebody
you are cat if you take a
employment position over somebody or a
leadership position over somebody as an
employee if you take a supervisory
relationship over somebody as a student
or whatever
you are
making the choice that we will never be
romantically engaged particularly if
they're gonna come back and work for me
um
wow what a mess i'm so sorry renee do
this let me know how it goes let me know
when you get the job let me know how the
uh conversation goes and let me know
what your next steps are um we'll be
thinking about this one we'll be right
back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy we don't do
it and we don't even realize they won't
even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john deloney show
listeners get 10 off their first month
so decide to invest in yourself you are
worth it and go to
betterhelp.com deloney to get 10 percent
off that's betterhelp.com
all right we are back let's go to
octavia in los angeles what's up octavia
how are you i am rocking onto the break
of dawn how are you
i cannot complain yes you can you'd be
like the rest of everybody but i'm happy
that you're not so good so what's up
well i just want to get a little bit of
advice um life just kind of went crazy
and um
you know i just want to see where
you'll be able to help me at and see if
maybe you can give me some cool advice
on moving forward out of this crazy
situation
all right let's do it i'm down some cool
advice
all right
so um
back i would say in may um i had a
landlord who
um wanted to wrongfully evict me stating
that someone else lived in my unit who
did it and um so we went through this
whole um
eviction process where i had to combat
the eviction
and in the midst of there my stuff was
locked into the unit um so on june 23rd
some kids got into the unit
playing
and burnt my house down
and
yeah okay hold on hold on so you're
were you behind on rent
no so he stated that someone lived into
the unit that didn't live in the unit um
did you have somebody over there a lot
like a friend or something then he
wanted to charge that person rent
no that's the thing i had to go through
this whole thing to prove to him that no
one lived there and i did
and um he stated that he was going to go
and clear the eviction with the courts
or however
and he never did
so all of a sudden i get this letter
that states that i have to leave out by
within the next three days
and for my knowledge everything was
cleared between the gentleman and i and
long story short he lied
and so someone went to court he lied in
court and um
yeah that's how come it went up to where
i had to actually
dispute it
did you win did you win the dispute
so in the midst of trying to do the
dispute is when the house burned down so
there's nothing to dispute anymore you
know who burned it
there still is actually but who burned
it down your nephews
no it was actually some people that
lived in the complex um and it was it's
called it's documented and everything
the fire marshals came the boy went to
jail and everything was set in stone in
that aspect um of knowing who did it
okay but the thing is um it's been very
hard for me to find a lawyer since then
that would take this case for um i was
advised that it's for negligence
because um on paper the the young
gentleman who burnt the house down did
state that all they did was slide the
window open so that means when the
landlord and the constable went to quote
unquote evict me
um they were supposed to lock up the
unit and they didn't because the little
kids said we slid the window open and
that's how we got into the unit so the
boy got in trouble
but i still need help with um
you know the situation with the landlord
for negligence
and on top of that
negligence in my experience is a very
high legal standard to meet
it's
hard
um
you've gotta
i say that like
it's gotta be very clear let me put it
that way like there's a hole in the
sidewalk and you step in and break your
leg like it's got to be very very clear
yeah
and that like what you're describing to
me just on his face i'm no attorney and
so i can't give you legal advice that
sounds like
a standard that will be nearly
impossible to meet did you have renters
insurance
so at the time i didn't
i just learned that
i had
canceled my renters insurance when the
eviction process started
i was advised that i have a really
amazing case because everything's
already documented um the court martials
they've already given me an estimate of
how much my stuff was in the house
um
the boy already was deemed guilty the
his lawyer stated that if i go after him
he does have to pay um so i have the
chief of the fire department stuff i
have all the paperwork from the um
police department
um so how can i help you
so um
going through all of that obviously made
me and my children homeless
and i have a 10 year old and a
six-year-old and after june 23rd when
the house burned down october
20th my daughter's dad passed away
so
that put me in a really hard financial
bind um i don't know any like no one in
my family has ever financially made it
anywhere um
okay so hold on if you have a place that
you're staying
and it burns down like if you're in a
hotel or if you're in an apartment part
of your lease states that they have to
find an alternative place for you to
live
they did not do that i know but i'm
saying is that you need to go to them
and say hey per my lease
um you've got to find a you've got to
provide me another place and i've had
people whose um apartments catch on fire
and they just live in a hotel for a
while and the apartment complex has to
pay that um
or if something
they've got to provide you a place
to be
i was not aware of that
me and my kids move pretty much to a
homeless shelter okay i would circle
back and here's the other thing do you
have the money to pay rent
i mean i'm working now
i am working now um i bet it's part time
so
i
have saved up money and
i was just trying to go through this
program to try to um
the road try to get me into like a place
or something
and i have been going through this
program pretty much since my place burnt
down okay
and i know that um you know i've just
been trying to look into
different things you know i'm definitely
into owning my own business
obviously i can't really do that in a
situation not having my own place
what you need right now more than
anything else
is
like you've been through a lot
yeah and my guess is how old are your
little ones
um ten and six okay mine are twelve and
six okay
and um is dad around at all or no
um he passed oh that's right you told me
that briefly i'm sorry
so like literally by myself yeah yeah
i left that state because it all
happened in las vegas that's kind of
what brought me here
um but you can go through this program
hold on
let's take a second
like the worst of the worst of the worst
has happened to you
and you're running and running and
running okay
so i need you to hear me say this really
clearly
when traumatic things happen our bod our
brains roll back into a very primitive
state which is one of survival one of
fighting or fleeing or hiding okay
and when our brain is stressed like that
we make very immediate decisions to try
to get to the next second
and that's often what traps people in
cycles that are very hard to get out of
okay
and so what i want you to do for just a
second
can you take a really deep breath for me
as deep as you can and just hold it
hold it
hold on blow it out that wasn't even
deep enough
do you vape
no good you can you can breathe deeper
than that then give it a shot breathe
deep
hold it
let it out
then i want you to drop your shoulders i
want you to pull them down
okay
what was what was um your child's
father's name
charles was it your husband
just long-term long-term partner
yes okay
so
charles is gone
and your home is gone
and i know you're running around trying
to super glue and duct tape and take
some string and sufficient line and try
to hold your kid's life together in your
life together
but the path forward to sitting down for
a second and just putting your face in
your hands
okay
you've got to give your body a chance to
settle into this
is what i'm saying ringing true
yes
i'm so sorry this happened to you
what just happened right in a road you
should not happen to anybody
not to mention the stress they were
already trying to take your house away
until some knucklehead burned it down
and at least you had a ride or die until
he passed and now you're in a mess
okay yeah
sprinting and running and thinking about
starting a new business that is down the
road right now
um you may have heard me say this on
this show by your hand not by your hand
but in your lap
you didn't cause this stuff but here it
is and so the dreams and the excitement
and the things
that just got pushed off because the
world just hit you in the mouth okay
and i hate hate in my guts that it did
so why did why of the one of the most
expensive places to live in the united
states is los angeles california why'd
you pick there
um
it's so funny that it really is but at
the same time
um
this is the one state that helps you you
know las vegas didn't have that i was
pretty much sleeping in my car
and i'm coming here although i'm in this
program that's you know it's like a
homeless shelter like pretty much women
with children in these huge houses
and um
they're helping me with las vegas i had
nothing um
you know the red cross didn't want to
help me um
no like i had nothing at least out here
it is the most expensive but i know that
everyone's afraid of scared row but you
don't have to be there like there really
are programs that'll give you housing
they're gonna help you you look for a
place they'll help you um
you know um different stuff like that
and then coming out here i ended up
getting a really good job and but but
it's part time right
yeah all right so here's your moving
forward goal
like my heart's broken for you
you're moving forward goal here is
putting on a calendar like maybe 24
months
maybe 18 months
and you are going to take this hurt
and this anger which should be real
someone burnt your house down charles
died man you should be pissed off
and heartbroken and sad all those things
and those two beautiful little kids
you know what i mean
who are hurting also
24 months
of maniacal
intense
i'm gonna work two jobs and four jobs
and seven jobs
or i may have to i know there's a cool
program and i know it's los angeles and
i know there's like some walk right in
for some setup
but if you got a family member in kansas
who will just let you hang on for 24
months
or if you got a family member in rhode
island or oregon
and you can
drum up some nickels and quarters and i
know gas is basically
liquid gold these days
but here's the thing
i just um
this morning was in a meeting with my
team
and a woman owed 267 000
all on her own
and she said never again
and she worked that way never again
and most people don't work that way
never again for two reasons number one
there's not a path forward
like i don't know what that looks like
even
and two
the world has told you that you're
powerless you're not worth being in
relationship with
and i i need you to hear me say octavia
you are strong
do you believe that
yes i do
you didn't say that with much confidence
you were much more confident about how
great the service the the services are
in california do you believe you are
strong
yes i i do okay
nobody in your family lineage has
handled money well have they
no no
you will be the one who changes your
family tree are you in
yes of course okay
there's a great quote by terry real
who's a therapist who i love
and he said
family dysfunction and family trauma
rolls downhill
burns through families like a forest
fire until one person
turns to stare it down and says no more
and that person gets scars and burned
and does not have all the shiny stuff
but their kids do
right right so i'm going to set you up
here's what i'm going to give you
um you know i work here at ramsey
solutions so i'm going to give you a
year subscription for free to ramsey
plus what that is is
that is how to do money 101
starting from the ground up it's the
same plan i use me and my family
that most of everyone who works here
does
it's the same plan that took dave from
getting um losing everything
to becoming he's got hundreds of million
dollars i can't count his net worth okay
but it all starts
at square one okay i'm gonna give you
that i'm also gonna send you a book
called total money makeover that's gonna
teach you about how to take control of
your money okay
i'm also gonna send you
my buddy ken's book
called paycheck to purpose did you
already send that to you
no okay i'm gonna send you that here's
what that job is i mean that book is
it's about how to get start from square
one
from zero
to go get work
that matters to you and that you matter
to the work because they're both of
those are important okay and
i'm gonna send you a copy of my book and
here's what my book's about just came
out it's number one bestseller
my book is
so you've had a life of trauma
and the world kept hitting you and they
kept hitting you and when you thought
you couldn't take no more then they took
charles
and
my book walks you through
and then the back half of that book is
so what do i do now
how do i stand back up on my two feet
how do i get a community around me how
do i look at my two little kids and say
we're in this together ride or die and
i'm gonna be the mama that none of the
people in my lineage have been before
okay i'm gonna send you all that
here's my pro you have to promise me
okay yes
a
with the ramsey with the um
ramsey plus
you have to watch all of the videos you
promise there's like nine of them that's
it promise i promise will you watch them
with your ten-year-old
yes watch them with your six-year-old
two we're changing family tree stuff
here right
yes
will you commit to finding a place to
live if you have to be in services for
the next i'll give you six months in los
angeles okay
okay
the way you just described the services
there is how people get trapped
because it is good there are some great
like your house just burned down here's
a place to come stay
but that can't be a two-year five-year
10-year plan for you okay
in los angeles i could not afford to
live in los angeles and i make a lot of
money i don't make a lot of money i do
well okay
i can't move there
you hear what i'm saying so at some
point you're gonna have to say all right
what's my path out of here
and paycheck to purpose will help you
figure that out okay
do you have somebody you can share life
with right now you have a friend a
relative somebody that can walk
alongside you
um
not really but okay i want you to
whether you go down to a local church
whether you
find somebody and scrounge up some
nickels and buy coffee
whether you get with one of the other
moms in that home that you're in
you have to make a connection with
another human you cannot do this by
yourself okay
okay you promise you'll do that
i promise you know why because you're
worth being in a relationship with and
you're worth being loved and you're
worth having somebody by your side fair
yes that's fair okay so today this all
changes
yes that's that's what i need set today
this all changes
today this all changes this is what i'm
talking about
and it might not all change you might go
back to the same shelter and you may go
have the same place with your kids and
your kids are getting out of school and
you're trying to figure out day camp for
summer and stuff like that
but in your head and then you're in your
guts
today is the day this thing all changes
right
right
so proud of you octavia today's the day
man
read the books
watch the lessons find somebody to do
life with it's gonna be hard sledding
for a few years hard sled and you're
worth every single step of the way we'll
be right back
hey delona here it's that time of year
where a lot of us are traveling again i
mean i've been traveling everywhere
flying driving living out of hotels and
that's all fun and good for a while but
it can be exhausting and it can wreck
your sleep that's why there's nothing
like coming home to your own bed
especially when you've got a world-class
mattress like dreamcloud dreamcloud
mattresses will make a massive
difference in the quality of your sleep
which is an absolute game changer
especially when you've been running hard
right now dream cloud is offering their
biggest deal ever exclusively for our
listeners when you buy a mattress you
get 499 bucks and sleep accessories plus
an additional 250 off that's a total of
749
in accessories and savings listen if
you're not excited to come home to your
own bed it's time to make a change visit
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get your new mattress today
that's dreamcloudsleep.com
promo code deloney
all right we are back let's go take one
more let's go to diane in des moines
what's up diane how are you doing
i'm doing fine how are you good good
good what's up
well i just found out that my daughter
is stripping and i don't know what to do
i want to go in with guns a blazing but
i feel like i will push her away and
this is a total 180 from what she was a
year ago and i'm just worried
something's going on
um yes something is going on what do you
think is going on
uh
well she's
trying to make ends meet she she was
living with her boyfriend that she'd had
for five or six years and
he was
basically
just living in the house and using her
vehicle and so she decided that was
enough and
she kicked him out well then she needed
to find some
way to either get a roommate or
make ends meet and so she stopped and
picked up
a waitressing job at a nice restaurant
and she was starting to make some money
um
she did have a girlfriend that i thought
she was
i had never never met
and i just found out that she
has been doing this before my daughter
started so i think something
the influences is pulling my daughter
away from what i've taught her too i
think she just looked at she she needed
them got desperate
and needed the money yeah um what what
is your relationship like with her
very close um just recently
um
she's kind of been pulling away um we
have opposite schedules since she's
working more evenings i'm
home in the evenings and and i work
during the day so are you in the same
town
close
close this is going to sound different
than the answer i would normally give um
but i'd go get my kid
um i would probably
um
like i i talk tough a lot about um not
letting your kids leech off of you i
talk tough about
um you know like when your kids 23 24 25
they need to have their own place they
need to go doing some go do some stuff
um
this is a critical juncture
um
there's the stripping yes but there's
also the environment and then there's
the secondary trauma and then there's
the
the
primary trauma
and the path here
stripping is included in the path here
which is one of um
it's just gonna be tough
like i'm just looking down the barrel of
what next year in the year after that
looks like
and this is one of those moments when i
would
ask my child to come to breakfast with
me
and i would say come home
you can live here for a year to get your
feet underneath you you don't have to do
this anymore
i'll take care of your bills i'm gonna
help you get a job i'm gonna help you
find some stuff come home
and she's gonna be taking some um she's
getting her masters hold on hold on hold
on hold on you're missing the point
she just has
so and i want her to come home i don't
think she'll want to come home okay um
here's what i want though
i want her to know mom fought for her
right
and mom didn't just call because our
schedules were just all screwed up for
screw my schedule i'm going to get my
baby girl you know what i mean
yeah and here's where it's going to be
devastating for you um potentially
because it's a risk you're going all in
yeah and if she does come home house is
gonna be a chaotic mess and you know
that because y'all probably fight and
don't get along
and you'll have different values and
different things it's gonna be a mess
but your baby girl will be safe at least
for a season
and
you can go out there and pour your heart
out and she can say no mom i'm just
making a thousand dollars a night i'm
not coming home
and then you're gonna make a long drive
back with nobody else in their car and
it's going to be heartbreaking and
devastating your little girl's worth a
potential heartbreak
am i right yeah yeah
so much
she's just got so much love in her heart
she does she does she has the heart of
gold and
i think she's gonna have so much
trauma and regret
and shame and
okay but listen she doesn't need any of
that from you right now
no what she needs is her mama
yeah she doesn't need any of that do you
know what's gonna happen and you're
gonna start using drugs and you're gonna
have mental health challenges and all
these men are gonna she doesn't need
that she knows that
she knows right
what she needs is somebody to say i love
you come home
right and she may not come
but in two years in three years
when the bottom falls out
when things start getting jagged on the
side
she'll say i know of a place
is dad still in the picture
um he's we're divorced we've been
divorced for five years and um
and his comment was
her friend does it i don't want her to
do it
but with the political things going on
right now people are doing things that
they don't normally
consider doing that's that's such a
stupid cop-out that guy needs to suck it
up and get off his butt and go get his
daughter
what kind of stupid thing is that to say
on the political stuff i don't care
what's going on
i know good grief and here's the other
thing i have to be honest about this
conversation it would be disingenuous
for me not to say
you may sit down with your daughter
who's getting what's your what's her
master's degree going to be in
social work okay she may be um
gonna graduate
and
this is a six-month stint
and she'll look up in five years and
have a great job as a social worker be
like yeah dude i just had to make ends
meet is this kind of part of the deal
and moving on i've met those folks
okay yeah not bad people
good people found themselves in a tough
patch and made decisions that i don't
think are good decisions i don't think
they're not they're good or they're not
healthy they're not good for you right
right nobody goes into that into strip
club the whole thing the exchange the
human it's a copy of a copy of what it's
supposed to be it's fake intimacy right
yeah nobody wins in that exchange it's
just sad it breaks my heart it does
because it takes something so right and
just says here's wallpaper and duct tape
and we can barely see through it
and
but she may lay out a plan for you say
mom i got four months and i'm gonna
graduate and i'm gonna go do this
um thank you so much but i'm a grown
grown up and i know what i'm doing
and
at that point you write letters you call
her
you say well we're having breakfast and
fix your schedule diane
yeah okay whatever whatever that takes
and tell that knuckleheaded ex-husband
of yours to shut up about the stupid
politics
call his daughter and let her know i
love you and you've got a place to come
home to
right
is it fair
yeah
i'm so sorry you found yourself in this
position um
there's just these and this is to all
the parents out there there's these
precipice moments
um maybe i hope this isn't a bad analogy
it might be i'm just thinking off top of
my head as i'm going here um i let my
kids climb trees all the time they're
always climbing trees and falling down
and doing whatever
there's a point though they get too high
up on that branch
are they probably going to fall no but
if they do they don't come back it's too
high it's too unsafe that that branch is
too flimsy
so i'm all about scratches and bruises
and failing and falling down
i'm about somebody gets in a bad
relationship and it's like
i love you i'm gonna stand by you
but you're 25 and you're making grown-up
adult choices
um
and then there's a few moments like
addiction
there's a few moments like
um
this when sudden when a a light switch
flips and somebody who was one person
becomes a completely different person
especially in that environment
it's just full of heartache and sadness
and
despair
and wrapped up in celebrations and loud
lights and loud music and beautiful
people it's just this despair
[Music]
then i'm gonna go get my daughter i'm
gonna go get my daughter
and if she doesn't come with me because
i can't force her and if he's gonna
she's gonna know that guy loves me
and that guy was willing to storm the
gates of hell to come get me
i see you
and i still love you anyway
that's what i want my kids to know we'll
be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to johndaloni.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right we are back as we wrap up
today's show
song of the day a little bit on the nose
here it's by the police
lead singer was sting
[Laughter]
that's some inside joke even though
we're all inside and y'all didn't get it
songs by the police it's called don't
stand so close to me and it goes like
this
young teacher the subject of schoolgirl
fantasy
she wants him so badly knows what she
wants to be inside her there's longing
the girl's an open page bookmarking
she's so close now this girl's half his
age
don't stand so close to me i've never
ever listened to the lyrics of the song
wow
don't stand so close to me
[Music]
i assure you i won't we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode okay so
you want a party husband's not so down
tell me more my sexual um
tendencies are more risque into the
abbreviations of bdsm
i don't know what else to do
that would get him to want to
participate in the ways that i need so
i'm not living that same old
regurgitated vanilla lifestyle the
regurgitated vanilla that's the kind of
sex that everybody likes is regurgitated
vanilla
my son
is
starting to become somewhat of an issue
from a behavioral standpoint due to his
mom essentially no longer playing any
sort of active role in his life where is
mom mom is currently in
a mental health facility outside of
philadelphia yikes man